while European NATO allies have focused
on arming Ukraine against Russia they've
neglected their own vulnerabilities
closer to home until that is vast
quantities of methane gas began bubbling
to the surface off the coast of Denmark
and Sweden in the Baltic Sea last week
underwater explosions caused damage to
both Nordstrom pipelines built to supply
Russian gas to Europe
NATO called it sabotage and despite a
lack of Hard Evidence pointing to
Russian involvement the alliance has
warned that it will respond to an attack
on allies key infrastructure and there
is real concern that the next Target
could be Norway now Europe's main gas
supplier in Russia's Place prime
minister Jonas garstor has confirmed
reports of unidentified drones cited
over Key Energy installations when
Russia is running out of options as they
are so what could they do and to my mind
going after the energy infrastructure is
one of the things they could do at
Norway's Museum of resistance
appropriately enough we meet defense
experts Sven holtzmark he's spent years
studying Soviet and then Russian
strategic Behavior Russia is left with
basically one semi-political weapon and
that is the export of gas to Europe
which has been severely restricted so it
gives a signal that okay if you continue
supporting Ukraine as you do
well we have the options to actually cut
your gas supplies from from from Norway
if indeed it was sabotaged by Russia
that disabled the Nordstrom pipelines
and that may never be proven of course
it would be a classic Act of hybrid
Warfare designed to damage critical
infrastructure with maximum deniability
and limiting therefore any direct
response
Norway is preparing for what may come
next deploying its military including
F-35 fighter patrols to protect oil and
gas installations Denmark Sweden and
Finland are also increasing surveillance
but NATO allies will know that such
hybrid measures are many and varied with
potential targets including not just oil
and gas infrastructure but also computer
systems electricity grids and thousands
of kilometers of undersea internet
cables they can't possibly protect it
all Jonah Al Jazeera Oslo